From NPR, this is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. There is so much in our culture that celebrates the power of positive thinking. We're often told to follow our hearts, to dream big. You can have, do, or be anything you want. Whatever belief you hold in your subconscious mind will become your reality, bottom line. Value yourself and believe in yourself. Because believing that the dots will connect down the road, will give you the confidence to follow your heart even when it leads you off the well-worn path.
来自NPR，这里是《Hidden Brain》，我是Shankar Vedantam。我们的文化中有很多东西都在赞美积极思考的力量。我们经常被告知要追随内心，要敢于梦想。你可以拥有、去做或成为任何你想成为的人。无论你在潜意识里持有何种信念，它最终都会成为你的现实。要重视自己，相信自己。因为相信未来的点滴终会连成一线，会给你勇气去追随内心，即使它把你带离了那条人迹罕至的道路。
But now, research a Gabrielle Eddie and says, maybe we should all dream a little smaller. Positive fantasies and daydreams as pleasurable they are, they have a problem when it comes to fulfilling our wishes and attaining our goals. Today as part of our U2.0 series, we bring you an episode from our archive that asks, is there a methodical way to achieve your dreams? Turns out there is, and this scientific technique has an acronym. Woop! Gabrielle is a professor at New York University, an author of the book, rethinking positive thinking inside the new science of motivation. She's from Germany, and she said growing up, no one told her to shoot for the stars.
但现在，Gabrielle Oettingen的研究表明，也许我们都应该把梦想做得小一点。积极的幻想和白日梦虽然令人愉悦，但在实现愿望和达成目标方面却存在问题。今天，作为我们U2.0系列节目的一部分，我们为您带来一期来自档案库的节目，探讨是否有一种系统的方法来实现你的梦想？事实证明确实有，而且这种科学技术有一个缩写：WOOP！Gabrielle是纽约大学的教授，也是《重新思考积极思考：动机的新科学》一书的作者。她来自德国，她说在成长过程中，没有人告诉她要志存高远。
The idea of big dreams, big hopes was if it all more implicit than explicit. When she came to the United States though, Gabrielle noticed a real cultural difference. Well, when I came to America, it was wonderful because people always said, yes, do it. Yes, that's possible. Yeah. Okay, this is a good idea. Why don't you do it? Whereas back in Europe, people were more cautious and said, you know, are you sure you want
大梦想、大希望的想法更多是隐含的，而非明确的。然而，当她来到美国时，Gabrielle注意到了一种真正的文化差异。嗯，当我来到美国时，感觉很棒，因为人们总是说，去做吧。是的，那是可能的。是的，这是个好主意。你为什么不做呢？而在欧洲，人们则更为谨慎，会说，你知道，你确定你想
to do this? Are you sure this is possible? So I was really happy to come to America because people were just sort of encouraging whatever idea you had. So yes, positive thinking, indulging in fantasies about the future does feel good. But when Gabrielle started to research this topic, she found something
这样做吗？你确定这可能吗？所以我很高兴来到美国，因为人们只是在鼓励你拥有的任何想法。所以，是的，积极思考，沉溺于对未来的幻想确实感觉很好。但当Gabrielle开始研究这个课题时，她发现了一些
interesting. Well, these positive fantasies, they seduce us to feel already accomplished and they take our energy away. So we found that, for example, they're more positively women enrolled in a weight reduction program, fantasized about their success in the program, the fewer pounds they lost, three months later, one year later, two years later, or the more positively university graduates fantasized about an easy transition into work life, the fewer dollars they earned two years later, the fewer drop offers they have gotten, and also the fewer drop applications they had sent out or take students. The more
有趣的事情。嗯，这些积极的幻想诱导我们感觉自己已经成功了，它们消耗了我们的能量。所以我们发现，例如，那些在减肥计划中对成功抱有更多积极幻想的女性，三个月后、一年后、两年后减掉的体重反而更少；或者那些对顺利过渡到职场抱有更多积极幻想的大学毕业生，两年后赚的钱更少，收到的工作录用通知更少，投递的求职申请也更少；或者以学生为例，越是
positively they fantasized about getting a good grade in their exam, the less well they did. The more positively they fantasized about getting together with a crushy, the less likely they were to actually get in a romantic relationship. Or take the health domain. Same thing, the more positively hip replacement surgery patients fantasized about an easy recovery, the less well could they move their joint, the fewer steps they could take, and the less well they recovered from the surgery. So when you look at each of these cases, I'm wondering if you could tell me what you mean
积极地幻想在考试中取得好成绩，他们的表现反而越差。越是积极地幻想能与暗恋对象在一起，他们实际上建立恋爱关系的可能性就越小。或者以健康领域为例。同样的事情，髋关节置换手术的患者越是积极地幻想能轻松康复，他们的关节活动能力就越差，能走的步数就越少，手术后的恢复情况也越差。所以当你审视这些案例时，我想知道你能否告诉我你所说的
by a positive fantasy. So let's take the student, for example, who is hoping to go out on a date with someone that he or she likes. You're sort of imagining, for example, going out on the date, things going really well, there's other person really liking you as much as you like them. Yeah, that's a good question actually. It's not so easy to measure these fantasies. So what we did is we gave participants a short story.
积极幻想是什么意思？让我们以那个希望与自己喜欢的人约会的学生为例。你可能在想象，比如，去约会，事情进展得非常顺利，对方也像你喜欢他们一样喜欢你。是的，这确实是个好问题。测量这些幻想并不容易。所以我们所做的是给参与者一个短篇故事。
So for example, in the case of the people who had a crush on someone else, a short story describing how they meet this person and they then needed to end that story. And that story could either end positively or it could end not so positively. So then participants fantasized and wrote down their fantasies about the ending of the story. And the more positively these people had been fantasizing about the ending of the story. And the more positively these people have been fantasizing about getting together with their crushy, the less likely it was that they actually got together with the person they were in love. So the idea really is the more idealized, the more positively people fantasize, the less
例如，在那些暗恋别人的人的案例中，给他们一个描述如何遇见这个人的短篇故事，然后让他们续写这个故事。这个故事可以以积极的方式结束，也可以以不那么积极的方式结束。然后参与者幻想并写下了他们对故事结局的幻想。而这些人在幻想与暗恋对象在一起时越是积极，他们实际上与心爱之人在一起的可能性就越小。所以真正的观点是，人们幻想得越理想化、越积极，他们
well they do because they don't put in the effort needed to actually reach the goals and fulfill the wishes. Now is it the case that people recovering from example hip replacement surgery when they have positive fantasies of walking at one level you would have to say this is deeply deeply understandable you know you you're you feel like you can't do the things that you're used to doing. You want to get back on your feet and you want to dream of the day when you would be able to walk or climb stairs or run without pain. Are you saying that that's a bad thing? No, I'm not saying it's a bad thing. Actually, we have very nice data showing that these positive fantasies they actually come out of a person's needs and you are completely right.
做得就越差，因为他们没有投入实现目标和满足愿望所需的努力。那么，对于那些从髋关节置换手术中恢复的人来说，当他们对行走有积极的幻想时，在某种程度上你不得不说这是非常非常可以理解的，你知道，你感觉自己无法做习惯做的事情。你想要重新站起来，你想要梦想有一天能够走路、爬楼梯或无痛奔跑。你是说那是一件坏事吗？不，我不是说那是一件坏事。事实上，我们有非常好的数据表明，这些积极的幻想实际上源于一个人的需求，你是完全正确的。
A person who has a surgery and who used to be able to walk feels a need to walk like before and they are the positive fantasies come from and I don't say these are bad things at all because they are the beginning of action, but they are only the beginning. They give action the direction, but they don't give action the necessary energy. In fact, when we induce participants to positively fantasize, to ideally depict them, positive future, then we find that the blood pressure goes down, and then we find that the feelings of energization go down,
一个做过手术且曾经能够行走的人，会感到像以前一样行走的需要，这就是积极幻想的来源，我一点也不认为这些是坏事，因为它们是行动的开始，但它们仅仅是开始。它们为行动提供了方向，但并没有为行动提供必要的能量。事实上，当我们诱导参与者进行积极幻想，理想化地描绘积极的未来时，我们发现他们的血压下降了，我们发现他们的活力感下降了，
and we find that people feel already accomplished. So they relax, they relax, because mentally, they are already there. There's something terribly sad about this, which is that the person imagines the happy future, perhaps because they're not very happy at the present, but by so doing, they in some ways deprived themselves of the energy and motivation they need to make their futures actually better, and thereby make their futures futures worse it feels like a vicious cycle. Well it is not so sad if you consider that if you actually complement these positive fantasies with considerations of what stands in the way, what is it in you that stands in the way that you actually fulfill your wishes and attain your goals,
我们发现人们感觉自己已经成功了。所以他们放松了，他们放松了，因为在心理上，他们已经到达了那里。这其中有一些非常可悲的事情，那就是一个人想象着幸福的未来，也许是因为他们对现状并不满意，但通过这样做，他们在某种程度上剥夺了自己使未来真正变好所需的能量和动力，从而使他们的未来变得更糟，这感觉像是一个恶性循环。嗯，如果你考虑到如果你实际上用对阻碍因素的考量来补充这些积极的幻想，即你内心有什么阻碍了你实现愿望和达成目标，
that then you actually get the energy and if these goals are attainable, then you really go for it. When we come back, we'll talk about the next steps to make that day dream a reality. You think about the next four weeks. Now in the next four weeks, what is your most important wish? Stay with us. Gabrielle Etienne has found that positive thinking, while fun, may not be the best answer to achieving your goals. But she does say that noticing your goals, thinking about what it is you want, can be a very
那么你实际上就会获得能量，如果这些目标是可以实现的，那么你就会真正去追求它。回来后，我们将讨论将白日梦变为现实的后续步骤。想想接下来的四周。现在，在接下来的四周里，你最重要的愿望是什么？请继续收听。Gabrielle Oettingen发现，积极思考虽然有趣，但可能并不是实现目标的最佳答案。但她确实说，注意到你的目标，思考你想要什么，可以成为实现这些梦想的
important first step in making those dreams a reality. You've done a lot of work looking not just at the potential downside of these positive fantasies, but also how we can use these positive fantasies in a very productive way and you call it mental contrasting. What is mental contrasting? Mental contrasting is a strategy to fulfill your wishes and attain your goals. So, you first identify a wish. A wish that is very dear to you. So, for example, you think about the next four weeks. Now, in the next four weeks,
非常重要的第一步。你做了大量的工作，不仅审视了这些积极幻想的潜在负面影响，还研究了我们如何以一种非常有效的方式利用这些积极幻想，你称之为心理对照。什么是心理对照？心理对照是一种实现愿望和达成目标的策略。所以，你首先确定一个愿望。一个对你来说非常珍贵的愿望。所以，例如，你思考接下来的四周。现在，在接下来的四周里，
what is your most important wish? It can be a professional wish, it can be an interpersonal wish, it can be important wish. It can be a professional wish, it can be an interpersonal wish, it can be health wish. This wish should be a wish that is a little challenging for you, but that you actually can fulfill yourself. Now identify that wish and keep it in front of your mind. What you do then is you think about
你最重要的愿望是什么？它可以是一个职业愿望，可以是一个人际关系愿望，可以是一个健康愿望。这个愿望应该是一个对你来说有点挑战性，但你实际上可以自己实现的愿望。现在确定那个愿望，并把它放在你的脑海中。然后你做的是思考
what would be the best thing, the best outcome if I fulfilled myself that wish. And once you identify that and put it in front of your mind then you imagine that best thing. If you recognize now imagining that best thing is like positively fantasizing. These are the positive datrums we are just talking about. But then instead of carrying on with these positive fantasies, you know which gears. And you say to yourself, actually, what stops me
如果我实现了那个愿望，最好的事情、最好的结果会是什么。一旦你确定了这一点并把它放在脑海中，你就想象那个最好的事情。如果你现在意识到想象那个最好的事情就像积极幻想一样。这些就是我们刚才谈到的积极白日梦。但随后，与其继续这些积极的幻想，你知道要换挡。你对自己说，实际上，是什么阻止了我
from fulfilling my wish and experiencing that outcome? What is it in me that stands in the way what is my inner obstacle? What is it in me? And then once you identified your inner obstacle and you need a little bit of humor
实现我的愿望并体验那个结果？我内心有什么阻碍了我，我的内在障碍是什么？我内心有什么？一旦你确定了你的内在障碍，你需要一点幽默感
and a little bit of honesty to yourself. Sometimes it's not so pleasant. You don't need to tell anybody, but you can identify that obstacle and then you say to yourself, if that obstacle occurs, then I will show a behavior or think outside to overcome that obstacle. So if obstacle, then I will behavior to overcome art too. And that's what in the science language is called mental contrasting with implementation intentions.
和一点对自己诚实的态度。有时这并不那么令人愉快。你不需要告诉任何人，但你可以确定那个障碍，然后对自己说，如果那个障碍出现，那么我将表现出某种行为或思考某种方式来克服那个障碍。所以，如果出现障碍，那么我将采取某种行为来克服它。这就是科学语言中所说的带有执行意图的心理对照。
And to forget this complicated name, it's called in the science literature also MCII. But we renamed it now and it's called now WOOP for wish. First we started with a wish. Outcome, we then went on to identify that outcome and imagine that outcome. Obstacle, remember the obstacle, identify the obstacle, imagine the obstacle and then the plan. The if obstacle, then I will overcome plan. And that's called whoop. I asked Gabrielle how she would apply her strategy to someone who has a crush on another person
为了忘记这个复杂的名字，它在科学文献中也被称为MCII。但我们现在给它改了名，现在叫WOOP，代表愿望（Wish）。首先我们从一个愿望开始。结果（Outcome），我们接着去确定那个结果并想象那个结果。障碍（Obstacle），记住障碍，确定障碍，想象障碍，然后是计划（Plan）。即“如果出现障碍，那么我将……”的克服计划。这就是所谓的WOOP。我问Gabrielle她将如何把她的策略应用到那些暗恋别人的人身上，
but instead of doing something about it just sits around daydreaming about a blissful honeymoon. How would that person use mental contrasting or whoop to achieve their goals? So let's say you have a young person who is interested in another person. And so the wish would be, you know, I want to go with him or with her on a date and want to explore a little bit deeper what that person is all about. So that would be the wish. The best outcome might be something like, you know, we would have a really good time and we would feel kind of in harmony. But then the person would change gears and say, what is it in me that stands in the way that I actually fulfill my wish?
但他们不是采取行动，而是坐着幻想幸福的蜜月。那个人会如何使用心理对照或WOOP来实现他们的目标？所以假设你有一个对另一个人感兴趣的年轻人。那么愿望就是，你知道，我想和他或她去约会，想更深入地探索那个人到底是什么样的人。所以这就是愿望。最好的结果可能是，你知道，我们会度过一段非常美好的时光，我们会感到某种和谐。但随后那个人会换挡并说，我内心有什么阻碍了我去实现我的愿望？
That I asked this person out for a date and experience the harmony. So what is it in me that stands in the way? And then the person might discover, hmm, I might feel too shy, or I'm a little bit anxious, reluctant to get a rejection, and then the person can elaborate on their China's to be rejected, that fear of rejection can really elaborate on it, kind of understand, oh yeah, this fear, that's my obstacle. And after that, the person could think, what can I do to overcome this fear of rejection? So what can the person do? The person can sort of understand, well, if the person rejected me, then I'm there where I'm right now,
即我约那个人出去约会并体验那种和谐。所以我内心有什么阻碍了我？然后那个人可能会发现，嗯，我可能感到太害羞，或者我有点焦虑，不愿意面对拒绝，然后那个人可以详细阐述他们对被拒绝的恐惧，那种对拒绝的恐惧，可以真正地详细阐述它，理解，哦，是的，这种恐惧，这就是我的障碍。在那之后，那个人可以思考，我能做些什么来克服这种对拒绝的恐惧？所以那个人能做什么？那个人可以理解，嗯，如果那个人拒绝了我，那么我还是处在我现在的位置，
because if I don't talk to that person, I will not meet that person anyway. So I can't really lose anything. And then he or she could do the if-then plan. If I feel that fear of rejection, then I will tell myself, just go to that person and approach him or her, because I can't lose anything. And then the person will non-consciously outside of awareness approach that person by sort of overcoming one's fears of rejection. One of the things that I find so striking is that third step doesn't
因为如果我不和那个人说话，我无论如何也见不到那个人。所以我真的没什么可失去的。然后他或她可以制定“如果-那么”计划。如果我感到那种对拒绝的恐惧，那么我会告诉自己，直接去找那个人并接近他或她，因为我没什么可失去的。然后那个人就会在意识之外，无意识地通过克服对拒绝的恐惧来接近那个人。我发现最引人注目的一点是，第三步并不
involve saying what are the obstacles in my path? But you ask, what are the obstacles in me that prevent me from achieving the score? That's correct, because the obstacles in me doesn't allow me to come up with all these excuses. So if I say, what are the obstacles in my path, I could say, well, this person is in a different building or whatever, or studies a different topic, or I don't have the time or I'm just
涉及说“我道路上的障碍是什么？”，而是你问，“我内心有什么障碍阻止我实现这个目标？”这是正确的，因为内心的障碍不允许我提出所有这些借口。所以如果我说，我道路上的障碍是什么，我可以回答，嗯，这个人是在不同的楼里，或者学习不同的科目，或者我没有时间，或者我只是
busy right now, and all these excuses, they fall away if you ask, what is it in you that stands in the way? What is it really that stands in the way? Now you extract the information out of that negative feedback without getting hurt, so you don't take it personally, but you take the information and compost in this negative feedback and you use it to make the correct plans. Has mental contrasting changed anything that you do? Well, I'm using a wolf on a daily basis and we have devised next to the book, we have devised an app which gives you the instructions
现在很忙，所有这些借口，如果你问“你内心有什么阻碍了你？”它们就会消失。到底是什么阻碍了你？现在你从那些负面反馈中提取信息，而不会受到伤害，所以你不会把它个人化，而是获取信息并消化这些负面反馈，并利用它来制定正确的计划。心理对照改变了你的任何做法吗？嗯，我每天都在使用WOOP，除了书之外，我们还开发了一个应用程序，它为你提供
of mental contrasting with implementation and intentions of Boop. So it leads you through the four steps, which outcome, obstacle, plan. And interestingly enough, I thought I'm an expert on poop, but I'm using the app every day actually. I'm using the app because it forces me to specify my wish, to specify my outcome, to imagine the outcome, to specify my inner obstacle, to imagine the inner obstacle, and to form a very specific if obstacle, then I will behave to overcome obstacle plan. So I do it every morning, other people do it in the evening or you know, doing lunch break or when they wait for the bus or in the subway. What you need though for doing a group, you need to have a quiet moment for yourself. You can be in some way when everybody is talking, but you need to be uninterrupted. You can't do your email, you can't talk to someone while you're doing a group.
带有执行意图的心理对照（即WOOP）的说明。它引导你完成四个步骤：愿望、结果、障碍、计划。有趣的是，我以为我是WOOP的专家，但我实际上每天都在使用这个应用程序。我使用这个应用程序是因为它强迫我明确我的愿望，明确我的结果，想象结果，明确我的内在障碍，想象内在障碍，并形成一个非常具体的“如果出现障碍，那么我将采取某种行为来克服障碍”的计划。所以我每天早上都做，其他人则在晚上做，或者在午休时，或者在等公交车或地铁时做。不过，做WOOP时你需要的是，你需要一个属于你自己的安静时刻。你可以在某种程度上处于人群中，当每个人都在说话时，但你需要不被打扰。你不能在做WOOP时处理邮件，也不能和别人说话。
So you need to have a moment for yourself where you think, what is my wish? What is my wish for today? Or you might think, what is my wish for the next four weeks? Or, what do I want in life? What is it really that I want? So you can whoop, very big wishes or you can whoop, trivial wishes. But what is important, it needs to be a wish which is dear to your heart. And the nice thing with whoop is that it also allows you to finally think about what do I really want. Gabrielle Etienne is a professor of psychology at New York University.
所以你需要一个属于你自己的时刻，在那里你思考，我的愿望是什么？我今天的愿望是什么？或者你可能会想，我接下来的四周的愿望是什么？或者，我一生中想要什么？我真正想要的是什么？所以你可以对非常大的愿望进行WOOP，也可以对琐碎的愿望进行WOOP。但重要的是，它必须是一个你内心珍视的愿望。WOOP的好处在于，它也让你最终思考我真正想要的是什么。Gabrielle Oettingen是纽约大学的心理学教授。
This episode of Hidden Brain was produced by Maggie Pennman and Max Nestrak. Our team includes Tara Boyle, Raina Cohen, Jenny Schmidt, Parts Shah, Thomas Liu, Laura Quarelle and Kat Shupnik. This week's Anson Hero is Jessica Goldstein, who is director of NPR's events and strategic initiatives. Since the pandemic began, Jessica and her team have pivoted to virtual events, bringing the same creativity and enthusiasm to everything they do. Jessica is someone who dots the eyes, crosses the teeth, and then goes back and cross checks everything again. Thanks Jessica.
本期《Hidden Brain》由Maggie Penman和Max Nesterak制作。我们的团队包括Tara Boyle、Raina Cohen、Jenny Schmidt、Parth Shah、Thomas Lu、Laura Kwerel和Kat Shupnik。本周的“无名英雄”是Jessica Goldstein，她是NPR活动和战略倡议的总监。自疫情开始以来，Jessica和她的团队转向了虚拟活动，将同样的创造力和热情带到了他们所做的每一件事中。Jessica是一个会把细节做到极致，反复核对一切的人。谢谢你，Jessica。
For more hidden brain, you can follow us on Facebook and Twitter. If you like this episode, please be sure to share it with a friend. Next week, we wrap up our YouTube.os series by looking at ways we can invite more empathy into our lives. Please join us then. I'm Shankar Vedantum, and this is NPR. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
想了解更多《Hidden Brain》，你可以在Facebook和Twitter上关注我们。如果你喜欢这一集，请务必与朋友分享。下周，我们将通过探讨如何将更多的同理心引入我们的生活来结束我们的U2.0系列。请届时加入我们。我是Shankar Vedantam，这里是NPR。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。